[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMRAT RAY: Hello, everyone.
Thank you all for coming
to this session, Istio--
Defense in Depth for Modern
Production Environments.
Today-- what are we going
to talk about today?
We're going to learn about how
Google Cloud and Istio gives
you the tools to help you
secure your production
environment like Google.
So a lot of what we're
going to talk about today
will be based upon what we have
learned over decades at Google
on how to implement
defense in depth.
And as part of this
we'll also talk about
what is Istio security
and how does it
play in the overall
security posture
that you may want to implement.
I am Samrat Ray.
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud,
working on various security
products, including Istio.
And with me is Tao Li.
He is the technical
lead for Istio security.
A quick note for folks who
haven't seen this before.
If you have questions,
if you open up your app,
you'll see a link
called Dory Q&A.
If you post your
question there, we'll
answer as many as we can now.
You can also post later, or if
there are too many questions,
we'll answer them offline.
So you can check it
after the conference,
like you can go back and check
for responses to your questions
later.
I will also be taking questions
here in the audience as well.
So let's talk a bit
about defense in depth.
Why now?
Why do we need defense in depth?
Why is this such a burning
topic at this point in time?
So one of the reasons
why defense in depth
is becoming more
important is because
of some of the emerging
trends in application,
both stack as well
as infrastructure.
Some of the trends that we see
is the adoption of containers
and microservices.
We see a rapid growth in
adoption of both paradigms.
Further, we see that the
deployment of these systems
happen to be on public
cloud, sometimes
on multiple clouds, and hybrid.
Lastly, the adoption
of microservices
also means that
every service can be
built in a separate language.
So we see a lot of heterogeneity
in the application stacks,
as well as in how they're
packaged and deployed.
There may be something that
you might call a service that's
deployed on a VM somewhere,
because it is a legacy system,
and then you build
your next generation
little microservices,
as you might call it,
and that's deployed as a
container in a Kubernetes
environment.
So we see heterogeneity
across the board,
and we all just see
a lot of services
that talk to each other.
So as you can see, there's a
bit of a communication sprawl
that happens within
your network, which
is far bigger than what used
to be the case, when you had
a clean three-tier
web app-based solution
or if you had a legacy system.
So how does this
impact security?
So first of all, we saw that
there was a lot of connections
between the services.
The connections also represent
a surface area of attack.
So there's a much greater
surface area of attack
if your perimeter is breached.
Further, as the
example here shows,
a compromise of a
shared service can
result in replay
attacks of identities
of a whole lot of
other services.
So your shared service can
escalate the privilege that
is actually available to it.
So here in this example,
we have a logging service
which you might think is
not that security-critical,
but imagine if it
was compromised.
Almost all your services
are authenticating
to the logging service.
And what we have
seen, another trend
that we have seen of late, is
that option of arrest as a way
to communicate between
services, and the use of bearer
tokens like JWT, for example,
or some opaque OAuth token,
but effectively a bearer
token, to authenticate
as part of the REST code.
So one of the challenges
of bearer token
is that a bearer
token can be replayed
by the recipient or anyone else
who is listening on the wire.
So thus, these credentials,
which you present as tokens,
can be replayed by a compromised
service like the logging
service, which can now suddenly
pretend to be service A
and start accessing data
from service B for data which
it should not have been
authorized to access.
So thus, this
impersonation is a problem
that we see because
of the increasing
use of bearer tokens as part
of our modern deployments.
The last point is,
as I mentioned,
your networks, your network
infrastructures itself.
Anyone who has access to
listen in on the network
can effectively steal
all user credentials.
Therefore your root in
network can effectively
become root in production, and
that's an undesirable security
property.
So what are the principles
of defense in depth
that we aspire to build as
part of our infrastructure?
So the first is you do create
a secure network perimeter.
The perimeter doesn't go away.
There is a value to having
a network perimeter,
and as Google, we have our
network perimeter, which
we, obviously, strongly defend.
But once you have built
your network perimeter
and you have done all
the hardening of it,
you effectively then
assume that your perimeter
has been breached.
Right after you build it you
assume it has been breached.
You assume that the threat
is inside your perimeter.
So thus, you now
have every service
that needs to
effectively establish
trust with any other
service that talks to it.
So in some sense, at a very
logical high level view,
every service has
its own firewall.
So you can think of them
as micro-perimeters.
And at this point
in time, because you
need to now monitor not just
the edge of your network,
you need to have some central
administration and monitoring
of every service endpoint that
exists within your network.
This posture has been
popularized as a term called
zero trust in the industry.
The term, I believe, originated
from an analyst in Forrester,
but now has been
increasingly been
adopted by a number
of security vendors.
Effectively, it's a way of
achieving defense in depth.
The key principle
behind it is that you
have peer-to-peer
trust models, and you
don't trust your
network by default.
Just because an
entity happens to be
within your network doesn't
mean it should be trusted,
even if it has a valid
application level credentials.
And we'll talk a bit
about the difference
between various layers
of identities that inform
a security posture like this.
So we talked about creating
a secure perimeter,
and Google allows you to
do so on a cloud basis
across all different
computational and service
types.
So if you have your
traditional VMs,
we have VPC networks
and firewalls.
We recently launched
to Kubernetes engine
private clusters that allow
you to build the perimeter
security for containerized
workloads running
in Google Kubernetes engine.
And one of the products that
is in private beta right now
is VPC service controls.
And VPC service
controls allows you
to extend this notion
of perimeter security
to fully manage services like
Google Cloud Storage or bit
query data sets, for example.
Now, having said that,
this is important to do.
One of the main reasons to
have an secure perimeter
is to mitigate
exfiltration risk.
Because you need some
chokepoint for you to control
outbound communication
to the internet.
And that's one of the big value
propositions of having this.
But having done that, you
need to think about defense
in depth, which this
session is about.
So we are going to
start with two concepts
that we have adopted
within Google
and on which our defense
in depth posture is built.
The first is BeyondCorp,
which has perhaps
been a little more
popular and many of you
might have heard about it.
And the other is application
layer transport security,
which is a paper
that we have written,
but it also informs some
of the key principles
of our production security.
So talking about BeyondCorp,
BeyondCorp effectively
is mainly applicable to a
human being, like an employee,
accessing sensitive data
in a corporate application,
for example, from their laptop.
So one of the first things
you want to make sure
is that you have a
strong identity that
is phishing-resistant
and a phishing-resistant
authentication.
I think we've seen a few
articles float by recently,
saying none of the
Google employees
have been phished in
the last few years.
The second is having
well-manage devices, which
are a part of your
security posture,
and they are actually-- the
status of your device actually
informs access.
Having well-configured TLS to
protect the data in transit.
Having a policy engine
that can actually
evaluate this
multi-factors in order
to decide what level of
risk that the request has
and then grant you access
based upon the risk assessment
of their specific request.
And a policy enforcement
point, which would typically
be reverse proxy on
your network edge
that can calculate all
of these attributes
and terminate the TLS, and
then that then forwards it
to the systems that are then
within your network perimeter
that you created.
This is BeyondCorp,
and as I said,
just because your
employee has a VPN
and is able to join the
network, every device
that joins your network
via VPN should not
have equivalent privileges
because your devices may
have different levels of trust.
If you were to use a
VPN software to join
in from a shared
desktop in a hotel,
it has very different
security properties
than using a very
well-managed desktop
in your corporate network,
and again, your mobile device
may have a different
security posture.
Thus they're not all equivalent.
And you need to have
application-level understanding
of the device and the
data being accessed.
Just having an LT understanding
tells you, can you
access this endpoint or
not, but you may actually
want to answer questions
like if you're coming in
from a mobile device, can
you access your compensation,
for example?
Yes or no, maybe yes.
Can you access the
compensation of your reports
and their reports and
so on and so forth?
Maybe the answer is
no, because if you
were to be senior enough
in your organization
and your mobile device
was lost or compromised,
a broach like that
would then result
in the leak of a large
section of employees,
their compensations can
be leaked, as an example.
Thus you can see it requires an
application-level understanding
of the posture, and it's
not just a network problem.
Application layer
transport security--
application layer
transfer security
is the counterpart to
what we do with BeyondCorp
but is optimized for
service-to-service
interactions.
And this particular
technology that we have built
has been optimized for Google's
production environment.
It is based upon the
same notions of not
trusting the network by default
but rather having strong peer
authentication and encryption in
transit, just like BeyondCorp.
But one of the key
principles, again,
just like we talked
about before,
is having this notion of
being able to establish
this trust at the
application layer
and remove any dependency on the
security of the network path.
So you don't have root
in network becoming root
in production very easy.
And lastly, the way to
implement this at scale--
and Google has hundreds
of thousands of services,
millions of endpoints--
is to be transparent
from the application code.
That's how we can enforce
this by default, using just
policies.
So how does ALTS work?
I'll go through this fairly
quickly but effectively.
ALTS consists of-- it's a mutual
authentication and transport
encryption system that
was developed by Google.
In some sense, it is
similar in concept
to mTLS, or Mutually
Authenticated TLS.
One of the key
aspects of ALTS is
that it authenticates the
identities of the service
and not the hosts.
So instead of authenticating
the IP address,
it authenticates identities
that are bound to services.
This trust model of
authenticating identities
makes it easy to replicate
load balance and reschedule
microservices across hosts.
So it enables the agility of
your authorization policies
and the resilience of your
authorization policies.
So the ALTS relies
on two protocols.
There's a handshake
protocol to establish
a key and a record protocol
to send the protected RPC.
The handshake
protocol is a Diffie
Hellmann-based authenticated
exchange protocol.
It supports perfect forward
secrecy and session resumption.
The record protocol
encrypts and authenticates
network traffic
using the protocol
secret that's been established
through the handshake protocol.
So that's great, Google
does this, but how
do you implement
something like this?
So one of the principles we
have within Google Cloud, one
of the approaches
that we are taking,
is that we want to
make these concepts be
accessible to our users
both on Google Cloud
and as part of a hybrid setup.
And towards that, for example,
the principles of BeyondCorp,
we are incrementally
building it into products,
like the identity of a proxy,
and VPC service controls,
and the principles of
application layer transport
security have been
built into Istio.
Today we'll talk more about
how we built this into Istio.
For a moment we'll do a
very quick, brief intro
of what is Istio, for
those who are looking
at this for the first time.
Given that this is
a security talk,
I'm going to speed
through this section.
Feel free to ask me
questions about it at the end
if you have more.
So Istio is an open
services platform
that's built to manage service
interactions on container
and VM-based workloads.
So it is built to handle
this kind of heterogeneity,
so it's not just a
Kubernetes thing,
though it's highly optimized
to work with Kubernetes.
Istio incorporates the
principles and learnings
that we have learned from
securing Google's production
environment with technologies
like ALTS and more.
While Google is
one of the founders
and significant
contributor to Istio,
there are other major
technology providers
who have also
contributed to Istio,
most notably Lyft, who
created the envoy proxy
that we have adopted as part
of Istio's technology stack.
So why should you
care about Istio?
Maybe you already have
a bunch of software
that does similar things that
allows you to create TLS,
allows you to observe traffic.
These are not new concepts.
The main value of
Istio, though, is
that it's an integrated platform
for a broad set of service
level network functions.
A couple of things--
one, we elevate
the principles to a service
level, versus thinking of them
at the network level.
And B, you get a single
integrated platform
that you can use both
for traffic management,
for observability,
like the latency
graphs that we showed
in our keynote earlier,
as well as for security.
Today we will focus on
policy-driven security,
and Istio implements that.
Before we dive into the
actual security pieces,
it's good to have a quick
overview of the components that
make up Istio.
So Istio itself
has a control plane
that consists of three things.
The first is Pilot.
Pilot is a control plane
to configure and push
service communication policies,
like, for example, service
discovery and even
authorization policies that
run within the envoy proxy.
The second is Mixer.
Mixer provides a pluggability
interface for you
to integrate both destinations
for monitoring and metrics
as well as policy enforcement
for policy providers.
Citadel is a core part
of Istio security,
and it enables you to
configure mutual TLS seamlessly
across a vast set
of services, and on
a heterogeneous infrastructure.
And it also provides a built-in
identity and credential
management.
So why do we use
proxies within Istio?
Mostly to normalize
across the heterogeneity.
The proxies give us
this normalization layer
and an abstraction
layer for us to be
able to have a homogeneous
policy enforcement
and monitoring capability,
while behind the proxy,
you can have different
languages, different deployment
models, and different RPC
protocols, for example.
So how does Istio enable
you to secure every service?
Istio does three simple
concepts, but three
very powerful capabilities.
It enables you to do mTLS for
authentication encryption,
and it allows you to do
this without any changes
to your application code.
Second, it allows you
to authorize access
based on service identity
or any channel attribute.
So thus, Istio enable
you to create policies
that allow you to define
who can talk to whom
and then monitor those
policies centrally.
Lastly, if you are using
modern RPC protocols,
like REST or gRPC, then you
can configure finer=grained
RPC-level access controls, and
we'll talk a bit about what
those are.
And these access
controls are what
really provides the
rich capabilities
that we leverage within
Google's production environment,
for example.
So why do we support
mTLS in Istio?
Well, it's policy driven
encryption in transit,
and as I said earlier, with
no application changes.
So that is a pretty
powerful paradigm,
because it's very complicated
to write good TLS code
and secure your keys and
maintain your certificates.
That's a lot of work.
So that's great value, but
it's the obvious value.
One of the key
principles that we
have within Google's
production environment,
which actually is
enabled through mTLS,
is strong authentication.
This is something
that's not so obvious
but is a very critical piece
of the security posture
that we enable through Istio.
So the authentication model
that we enable via Istio
is that the peers are
always authenticated
using non-replayable
service identities.
And we make those identities
non-replayable by binding them
through the TLS channel.
So you might call them
channel-bound service
identities.
Thus those identities cannot
be replayed by the recipient
or anybody who is trying to
sniff on the wire, because A,
they're encrypted on the
wire through TLS, and B,
the recipient where you actually
terminate the TLS does not have
the private keys in order to be
able to replay the identities.
A very critical piece
here to understand
is that this does
not necessarily
represent your application
level identity.
So to take a very
concrete example,
if your service B were
to be a MySQL database,
you would still have
a MySQL level identity
that you propagate, which
the MySQL database is using
for fine-grain authorization,
like which table,
which row, et cetera,
do you have access to.
That floats on top as part
of your call to MySQL.
What we are enforcing here is
the notion of a service such
that even if you had the
valid MySQL credentials,
we want to ensure that you
are actually a service that
is authorized to talk to this
specific MySQL database--
so service-to-service trust
versus application-level trust.
So one of the things we realized
after we launched this was that
customers cannot go from no
mTLS to all mTLS on day one.
The reason is you mostly
will have services
that have many clients.
Sometimes you don't even realize
the clients that you have
for a given service, and
you cannot imagine that all
the clients and their clients
and their clients all get
enabled with mTLS on day one.
So because of that we created
this mode within Istio
called permissive
mode, which allows
you to incrementally apply
mTLS to an existing service.
So for example, you can
start with a service that
pertains to your
most sensitive data
and then take the most
sensitive client part, a path
that you want to
secure, and just secure
that first while still allowing
requests from other clients.
For example, a health
checker service
may be also accessing
that service,
but you don't need that to
be mTLS-enabled on day one.
But your health check service
doesn't break just because you
have secured your data path.
And this is a very
powerful capability
that we have built
into Istio and would
be available as
part of version 1.0,
which we are launching shortly
Once we have a strongly
authenticated service identity,
we can now use that
for authorization.
And to understand
Istio authorization,
you have to understand
the notion of a service.
A service has a bit
of a dual identity.
It's both a network
identity as well as
an application identity.
And here, identity, I don't mean
in terms of actual credentials,
but in terms of personas.
It can be thought of
as a network entity,
or it can be thought of as
an application level entity.
So a service, therefore,
spans the stack
that I've shown
here, which is you
can have a service be
understanding channel level
attributes, like IP address.
The service identity
that's on the TLS
channel or the Kubernetes
namespace, for example,
as part of the context
in which it is called.
At the application level, the
first thing it can understand
is your API or RPC-level
artifacts for protocols
like HTTP or gRBC.
So for example, what's the
URI, what operation is getting
called on it, and what
are the various claims
that are encoded in a
JWT token, for example.
So thus, you can use a service
level authorization policy
like Istio's policy
to do both what
traditional
micro-segmentation allowed
you to do by leveraging
channel attributes
and saying who can talk to whom,
just in pure tones of channel
attributes like namespaces, for
example, or just identities.
A key thing which
Istio enables you to do
is to trust that identity.
So you can actually do something
that's more natural to you.
As in, which service can talk
to which, versus which namespace
can talk to which.
Which is little second order in
direction of what you're really
trying to express.
This is more closer
to the intent
that you want to express
by using identities.
But a very powerful
thing that is
enabled though
Istio is to combine
this notion of a
service identity
with elements that
are available to you
at the API or the RPC level.
And then create a
powerful mechanism
to determine a
composite policy, like,
for example, what
operations can be performed
by whom and through which path.
Let's take a concrete example
to understand such a policy.
So here's an example.
Joe here is an authorized user
and is a support engineer,
for example, who
has access to PII.
But the only way he
should have access to PII,
which is the
organization's policy,
is by using a CASE tool.
And the CASE tool then
validates that Joe
is making an access with
the proper case identity,
for example.
There's really a
case, a valid case.
And the user's data
that Joe is fetching
is relevant to that case.
And there's a
business logic that's
built into the CASE tool.
The back end is configured
to say Joe has access to user
data, however, Joe cannot
directly access the back end.
In such a scenario,
Joe then decides
it's pretty inconvenient
for me to do this CASE tool.
I need to do some research
on a particular issue
and look at it across
a bunch of users.
Why don't I just
create my own little BI
tool, a dinky little BI tool,
and then enable it with mTLS.
I obviously have access
to PII on the back end,
and just use the tool
to then access the PII.
Now this, while from a
back end perspective,
application-level perspective,
seems just fine, right?
Joe is authorized at
application level to access PII.
But now you're
bypassing a tool that
was meant to implement a bunch
of the organization's policies.
And that should not be allowed.
So here's an example
of a policy file
that not only checks that
the user on the chart
belongs to a particular
role, like reader--
so for example, you could
substitute that by support,
for example, that has
been authenticated,
say, from your Active
Directory system
and then encoded as a
JWT claim, but it also
checks that the service
level identity is actually
the CASE tool and not the dinky
little app that Joe created.
Now, when you implement
such a policy,
it now ensures that
you have locked down
the path for privileged
access to ensure
that only an authorized
user can access it,
but very importantly, using
just the right client.
This is a very
powerful principle
that is enabled to protect
highly sensitive PII
data or other kinds of sensitive
data from insider access.
And this was
something, for example,
it's just not possible through
traditional micro-segmentation
approach.
Micro-segmentation still
enables you to prevent
lateral movement of threats.
There are other
benefits to doing
classic micro-segmentation, but
here you get benefits of both.
Through mutual
TLS, we explain how
you can prevent lateral
movement of threats
through the implementation
of mutual TLS,
and now with these kind
of authorization policies,
we show how you can
protect sensitive data
from unauthorized
insider access.
Lastly, as I mentioned, you
need to monitor your posture.
Once you have
implementing policies
at scale like this over a
large number of services,
you do need to have a consistent
visibility of security posture.
And that's what Istio really
enables you to do, is--
everything that
I described could
have been implemented within
your application logic.
The reason to do it
in Istio is, one,
you free up your developers.
Your developers can just
focus on business logic,
and not everyone is
a security expert.
So they can move very
quickly without having
to learn all of these concepts.
But more importantly,
the developer
can use a language
of their choice.
They can use an RPC
protocol of their choice.
They can use a deployment
paradigm of their choice.
And you can move things around.
You can go from VM to containers
to cloud or back on prem.
And while doing so, as a
security administration
function, you'll still have
a consistent visibility
of your security
posture, no matter what
is happening on the stack.
This allows you to go through
a whole IT transformation
while maintaining
a security posture
and you're defensing
the posture.
So this is another
very powerful paradigm
that Istio enables
you to practice.
With that, it's time to take
a look at how this actually
works in practice with
Istio as it stands today.
For that I'll invite Tao to
walk you through a quick demo.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TAO LI: So hello, everyone.
My name is Tao Li.
Today I am going to give you
a demo about Istio's security
features.
So the agenda includes--
[MICROPHONE FEEDBACK]
SAMRAT RAY: Do you want
to use mine instead?
TAO LI: Can I have just a mic?
Oh, OK.
OK.
So the agenda
includes four items.
The first one is the
policy-based mTLS
authentication.
The second one is
identity-based authorization.
The third one is about end
user identity verification,
and the fourth
one is monitoring.
And I'm going to use a
pretty simple example
to walk you through what
Istio security can do for you.
Let's say you are
developing this simple app.
This one has a front
end and have a back end.
So the end user call
the front end and front
end will get the
data from back end
and send it back to end user.
So this is pretty simple,
but in this model,
you can see currently
there is no traffic
encryption and no access
control and no monitoring.
So what we can do is
once you install Istio,
Istio can handle all the
security stuff for you.
So you don't have to
spend a lot of effort
to implement security
code, and Istio will
handle this feature for you.
You can focus on your
own business logic.
So as you can see here,
once we deploy Istio,
Istio is a sidecar proxy
that deployed right next
to your service.
Each of your servers, you
have an Istio sidecar,
and this proxy
will intercept all
the incoming and
outgoing traffic.
And besides that, Istio
have a ingress path.
So this one is also
an envoy-based proxy,
and all incoming traffic
will go through ingress
and then go to our front end.
So this model has a problem.
Let's say somebody
hacked into your network,
was in your own network.
So within your
network, the hacker
can talk to the back end, even
when your back end has some PII
information.
So how do we solve that?
So with Istio,
you can force mTLS
once you enforce mutual TLS on
your front end and back end.
So in that way, the client needs
to provide a valid certificate.
So since this
hacker was in there,
they only hack into the
network, but you're not
having enough privilege
to join the mass, which
means you don't have a
proxy that will show you
that this attack
will be stopped.
And this about what
mutual TLS can do.
Of course, mutual TLS can
encrypt the traffic for you.
So sometimes we feel like the
mutual TLS are not enough.
We need some access control.
Imagine you have a front
end and a back end,
but normally you can have
like 100 or 1,000 other apps.
For example, in
Samrat's example,
you might have a logging app.
So if this one get
compromised, this logging
belongs to a totally
different department
and is not supposed
to call the back end.
But because this
one has a proxy,
this one could get a key cert
from our Citadel, our control
plane.
So chances are, this logging,
once it gets compromise,
so bad guy can hack
into the logging system
and call the back end to get
your sensitive information,
like your credit
card information.
So what we can do is we just
deploy Istio access control
on our back end.
So once we have
this one deployed,
we will specify that only front
end can access the back end.
So that the logging, even
if you had a valid key cert,
you cannot talk to the back end.
So we're talking about
two inside attackers,
and we haven't really
focused on the end users.
So right now, from
end user, end user
has not provided any token yet.
So what if we have a malicious
guy outside of the network,
and they're trying
to do the same thing
as our normal guy do?
So they will try to
call our front end,
so the traffic will
still go through.
So chances are you can also
implement your own end user
validation system, but
Istio provides this for you.
So you don't have to
really worry about it.
And what we can do--
I'm going to show you is when
we enforce this end user token
check at our front end so
the hackers cannot talk
to the front end any more
because they don't have a valid
token.
But for our normal person,
for example, our admin,
you can actually
have the access--
you have access to
the end user token,
for example, the JWT token.
So you are able to
access the network.
And the last one I'm
going to show you
about the monitoring stuff.
So let's look at the demo.
Can you switch to demo, please?
OK, so lets look at it.
I already have this demo set up.
So you can look here--
I have a product page
which is our front end,
and we have details,
which are the back end.
Each of them already
have a sidecar,
because it has the
two contenders.
And I have Istio control
plane deployed already.
So right now there is no Istio
security feature applied yet.
So if we look at this page,
this our online web page.
From external, you can
access this web page.
But you can see here, we have
some sensitive information
like credit card information.
And as I mentioned, the first
thing I'm going to show you
is if somebody hacks
into your network,
for example, this is a GKE node.
This one is within the network.
So if someone hack
into the network--
so what this guy can do,
it will call our back end.
This is the IP address
of our back end.
So they can call back and to
gather sensitive information.
For example, you can see
the credit card shows here.
So what we can do is
we apply mTLS policy.
By the way, this K is
just my alias for kubectl.
So right now the
policy is deployed.
Let's look at the policy first.
So this policy defines enforced
mTLS on default namespace.
So our front end and
back end both deployed
on default namespace.
So once you deploy
this page, you
will see that the front end and
back end both required a peer
to present a valid cert.
So that means, for this case,
if you're within the network
but you don't present a
key cert, you will see--
you don't present
a client cert, you
see the traffic got rejected.
And from our normal
web page, it always
work because it's from ingress,
and to front and back end,
everyone has proxy.
So this is mTLS.
The second thing
I want to show you
is about the access control.
I mentioned, we have
a log-in system,
and I actually called it
asleep path in my case.
So we have a path here.
This one had a sidecar
deployed, and I'm
going to show you that
when I SSH into this part,
I can talk to the back end.
So you can see this
is the credit card
information, shows up here.
Either you have mTLS, because
this guy also have a client
certificate, so he
cannot prevent this.
And what I can do is I will
apply this access policy.
Now let's take a
look at the policy.
So what this policy does, it
enabled RBAC on the default
namespace right here--
by the way, RBAC is a
Role-Based Access Control.
So Istio uses the RBAC
to do the access control,
and this one defines RBAC on
our default namespace, which
is our front end and back end.
So let's look at the
actual service row.
We have two rows.
The first service row is
about the product page,
which is our front end.
So this one defines a get
permission to the front end.
And you can see the user's a
star, which means right now,
in this policy, everyone can
have access to the front end.
Of course, you can set
more strict policy.
But the more interesting
thing is here.
So if you look at here,
another service row
defines the get permission to
the details, to the back end.
And who do we bind
this permission to?
You can look at
here, this is a user.
This product page
is our front end.
So once we deploy
this policy, you
can see that only front
end can access back end.
But everything now, if you
have a client certificate,
you cannot access anymore.
So let's take a look.
So this is the one
I tried before.
So once we take a
look at this one,
you will see there should
be some error here--
403 forbidden.
So once we have
this, you can see,
if you have clients certificate,
you cannot access it
because you don't have the--
we set the access control.
And from here, since I set up
the access control properly,
so the front end can access it.
So this page is still there.
So this is about mTLS
and the access control.
So this third one I want to
show you is about the end user.
So the end user is,
sometimes, as I mentioned,
we want to define
some policies such
that the end user needs to
present me some valid token.
Otherwise I'm going to stop you.
So if you look at this example,
right now from this web
page, the end user--
the browser does not
provide any token yet.
But this traffic can
still go through.
So I'm going to
enforce some policy.
Let's take a look.
So I deploy this JWT
authentication policy.
Let's take a look at
this policy first.
So this policy applies to
our product page, which
is our front end, and
it requires the peer
to present a certificate,
which the peer is mutual TLS,
and a region besides the peer.
We also want to specify,
say a region of this color
will need to--
we require a JWT.
So this is a issuer
of the JWT, and this
is where you can
fetch the public key
to validate this JWT.
So once we specify this,
let's look at this page.
The policy may take
a while to propagate.
So you can see this
original authentication
failed, because this one
doesn't have a valid token.
And what I can do is I prepared
a valid token, actually,
right here, beforehand.
And let's see.
From this page, this one
still works because this guy
present a valid token.
And this is about end
user verification.
The last one I want to
show you in the demo
is about the monitoring.
So Istio Integrate
was a Grafana,
which is an open source tool
for you to monitor the traffic.
So from here, as
you can see here,
we have a different service.
You can select a
different service
and you can select
different stuff.
And the x-axis is the time,
and the y-axis is the QPS.
So you can see here.
This red line means the default
production page default 200.
So this one is before
we enforced mTLS.
So you can see this
is the first traffic.
So after we enforced
mTLS, you can see this--
the product page
default 200 mTLS.
So from here, all
the green lines
means something that is
the traffic generated
after we deployed mTLS.
And besides, we also
have some purple lines.
The purple lines
means we had 401s.
That's because we called this
one, the traffic got rejected.
So that's pretty much
about the demo part.
We talked about mTLS.
We talked about access control.
We talked about end
user verification.
We talked about the monitoring.
And the last thing, this is
pretty much about the demo.
And switch back to
the slides, please.
OK.
So beside that, we'll
have more stuff coming.
As you can see here, we have
Istio 1.0 coming pretty quick,
and that will have
over a year's work.
And we have managed
Istio on GKE that
would provide a best Istio use
experience across all the Cloud
platform.
And another thing is,
besides this talk,
we have other talks
about container security
within this next event.
So stay tuned.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]